[Applause]
you excited about this you're ready to
go and yeah yeah it's gonna be a lot of
fun the whole turn over a new leaf that
whole thing yeah it's also it's a big
thing here in New York City you know and
I know if people are here at you know
home watching the show or where but you
know it is almost New Year's even well
they have this big deal in Times Square
where they drop this ball you know as
you folks know that the ball glides down
towards Times Square right before New
Year's Eve and Dick Clark hosts this
annual event
on New Year's Eve right on ABC and it's
it's really a big thing a lot of people
really enjoy this and I thought it might
be fun to well to check in on the balls
progress it's a I understand it's still
actually in outer space right now it's
traveling towards Earth it's making its
way and we actually I think Dana have we
been able to get a satellite picture of
the ball heading towards Times Square we
have can we show it well there it is now
see the ball has an uncanny ability to
it hones its way into Earth it's
approaching it's just a couple thousand
miles away now it's getting closer and
closer and actually you can see the ball
has a porthole maybe we should check
inside and see what's going on there
actually somebody sleeping in there well
actually I think that that's that I
think it's Dick Clark was actually he's
in the ball and he's uh this is what he
does he sleeps actually throughout the
entire year you know this is how he's
preserves himself Wow yeah this is why
he looks so incredibly young and he's
getting up now because it's just about a
day away and he's getting closer to
Earth and data preparation a lot of
preparation he's got to do and he's it's
very exciting
so folks what we'll do is I will check
in with the ball maybe throughout the
show and just see as it gets closer and
closer to Earth it's a it's a fun little
great yeah other shows don't think to
check in with the ball mm-hmm parallax I
really can't understand it all right now
folks with the with the new year ending
Andy and I well we thought we'd make
some new year's resolutions it's sort of
become a what's become a tradition here
at our show and and we were going to
make these resolutions here tonight but
then actually I looked at last year's
resolution show where we made all these
promises and well I got to thinking
maybe we just maybe we just shouldn't
make any promises at all this year take
a look this is last year's resolution
clip and you'll see what I'm talking
about I'll tell you one thing Andy in in
1994 I promise I'm really gonna try to
treat guests with patience and
understanding you used to get up at 4:00
every day just to do your routines and
practice I mean that must've been really
tough it really was I mean but I'm sure
you understand I'm sure you have to get
up pretty early to get your hair to look
like that we have to do a commercial for
just one second
but if you can stick around be right
back with more Mary Lou Retton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well you know in the coming year I
promise to be tolerant of all guests I
get a great idea we're gonna do a show
okay I'm gonna have both of you on
together oh baby nice I will talk to a
star and a sidekick
okay star sidekick okay this show is a
step up yeah
so I come in I meet a Neanderthal what
exactly does he be you want to know what
I do this is what I do
I'm gonna show respect to anyone that
comes on to go and all of a sudden the
army helicopter makes this giant turn we
go all the way back to France and in
fact we find out that the United States
Army
[Applause]
and especially former politicians I was
the mayor of New York City for 12 years
[Applause]
he and I both promised to really watch
our language during the coming year that
Florence I have to ask you about the
character of Marsha I mean that was the
step that's a great character yeah she
was soaking hot yeah she was really like
the most best damn babe I know it was
funny because she could just come the
rest of the characters so much just such
a just a trip to say yeah sure so sweet
so righteous yeah sometimes I used to
think that bit Mike he seemed like a
real I mean you know I was like what you
know what I mean like he's just his
advice yeah it's just like if there's a
rod up your just take it out but you
know myself for a laugh in a comedy bit
it's cream of wheat time come on indeed
oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm gonna personally make sure that on
this show we do not portray women in a
demeaning manner at my side mrs. Marcos
I have no comment any abuse me and junk
george herbert walker bush you're going
to be sick
don't be ridiculous I feel fine
[Music]
Just Peachy that you and I albeit
spending summer school together
[Applause]
who are you supposed to be Conan I some
people came by I I wanted to fit in so
call me Liza now I will never ever let a
lunatic take control of my show I'm
going to enter the race for the
presidency of the United States and
everything you know what I'm sick and
tired of house divided hmm and that
cannot stand i don't care if you're
democrat or republican i want to know if
you're an american i say this to you
conan the myth that you're in a 49%
bracket with the IRS that's communism
and that's tyranny
[Applause]
Nicole and I promise you I will never
miss a show for personal reasons I swear
there's a slight change tonight as you
can see my friend Andy isn't here
well Andy had to be somewhere else on
pressing business and well I guess the
quickest way to explain exactly where he
is is AB Dana could we just turn the
signal over to court TV please and take
a look yes yes I am yes can you work out
what happened to you that morning well I
was standing out in the middle of the
field and I felt something hit me at the
time not right away no where were you
hit in the ear this misdirection
and the PRT not not physical pain now
what did you think it was that hit you I
thought it could be a fish almost
chicken breast were you on the scene
when the police arrived yes yes I was
did you tell them what happened I ran I
resolved right now to participate in
charity events all the young people are
now finding out what all the older
people found out when they first heard
him and now he has a whole new audience
and so does he deserve this Conan
O'Brien
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's clear
they get along
[Music]
[Music]
you know Conan I'm not gonna go to that
cheap Woodstock - you know that
commercial ripoff whatever they're
calling it I'm not gonna go
[Music]
[Applause]
we didn't do too well good way kept that
one alright folks as you can see we're
not gonna try and make promises this
coming year but I will have one of the
lovely ladies from Baywatch when I come
back Yasmine Bleeth will be here